a visionary a revolutionary the son of a
nation for the nation not just lyrics to
his song 34 years after the
assassination of burkina faso's
president
he's still revered by millions of people
across french-speaking africa
1983 he was described as a feminist and
environmentalist than a 33 year old
soldier he was ahead of his time he
turned his back on international aid
money and loans from organizations like
the world bank instead favoring
self-sufficiency in calling for a more
equal relationship with france the
country's former colonial power on the
15th of october 1987 sankara was killed
by an armed group along with 12
officials his closest friend and former
colleague bless compare took power
he along 13 others were on trial accused
of murdering sankara
bless compare was ousted in 2014
following a popular uprising that
brought an end to his 27-year rule he
lives in exile in neighboring ivory
coast and refused to take part in this
trial his supporters saw it as a
political witch hunt
according to official government
documents sagara died a natural death
but in 2015 authorities exhumed his
remains from a grave an autopsy revealed
his body was riddled with bullets
in 2017 french president emmanuel macron
agreed to release secret files on
sankara's death that led to the opening
of the trial those behind
the assassination sought to
silence sankara and his ideals but it
had the reverse effect millions of
people across french-speaking west
africa see in sankara a symbol of
resistance against the powerful he's
become a hero and an icon celebrated in
arts culture and politics
many of those involved in the recent
cohen malian one in guinea last
september have referenced sankara's
leadership as an inspiration
these are some of his last words in
public
we need to accept we are africans it's
the only way to live with dignity
sankara says adding do you want to see
corrupt government officials or soldiers
then we will get rid of them this may
cost me my life but we are here to dare
shortly after this speech
sankara was shot dead
nicholas huck is following developments
from dakar in senegal so nicholas we've
got a sentence in but would it ever be
carried out since compare is in exile
that's right i mean
president bless compare former president
bless campari heard this verdict from
his plush
villa outside of the capital of abbey
join ivory coast where he lives in exile
and there's no extrajudicial extra
judiciary extra judicial kind of
agreement between ivory coast and
burkina faso at the moment so under the
current presidency of ivory coast
president watara it's unlikely that
kompari would serve time or would be
extradited to go to burkina faso to
spend time in jail however for
his right-hand man general gender who
was already in prison for uh an
attempted coup
a couple of years ago well he is likely
to serve the rest of his time in prison
in burkina faso this is from any uh a
victory for the rule of law in this
country
given what you've just said nick how far
will this trial go in actually closing
this chapter and actually healing the
deep wounds which the assassination of
sankara left in people's psyche
well we have to remember this is a trial
in waiting for the last 35 years people
have been waiting for this sentence to
come for the trial to take place and
it's interesting to see somebody how
many young people are taking to the
streets that weren't alive when this
murder took place why because sankara is
much more than the former president of
burkina faso he's an icon he's a
pan-africanist he's the che guevara of
africa and it's the circumstances of his
death that made him such a hero a young
captain killed by uh
by president bless compare but what the
trial didn't tell us is what was the
implication of foreign powers
emmanuel macron the french
notably this is a former french colony
president emmanuel macron 2017 had
promised to release secret documents
linked to the killing of sankara only a
fraction of those documents were made
public so the
circumstances of his death the
involvement of france perhaps or also
ivory coast or togo well the
circumstances of his death is still
shrouded with some element of mystery
and that has only served to make him
even more of a hero remember sankara
was a young soldier that promised a vast
amount of change in society and the way
that many people or burkina faso young
burkina faso were being led so he
promised a change from the past a break
away from france the former colonial
power but also from international
organization
saying that he would bring in
self-sufficiency in a famous quote sammy
he said we must choose for champagne for
a few or safe drinking water for all and
that's why so many people are happy with
this trial and this sentencing sammy
good stuff there nicholas huck from
dakar